it was a very difficult decision for us
to make
but this has been an incredible journey
and we have told the story that we
wanted to tell
the way that we wanted to tell it sad
news on
gma this morning groundbreaking lgbtq
plus series pose will be ending after
its third
upcoming season totem pole
origami the series made history for
featuring
the largest cast of transgender actors
ever and back in 2019
when we caught up with star india more
she told us
the importance of sharing trans stories
the show demonstrates the perspective of
a
very marginalized group that is rarely
heard
you know people don't know what the
experiences of trans people
are so it shows an incredible
opportunity to create connections
between
a very marginalized group of people the
whole world thinks we're not but freaks
we're supposed to be working in a shadow
somewhere
and if anybody's looking at us they're
laughing in 2019
billy porter became the first openly gay
black actor to be nominated
and win a primetime emmy for outstanding
lead actor
in a drama series i think being black i
know
that being black and gay and out
and being in this position
and speaking from where i get to speak
from
is the change i hope that
young queer people of all colors
can look at me and know
that they can and when we caught up with
billy he told us
the importance of these stories coming
from an authentic place
i feel like our stories are being told
by the people who lived it sometimes
family is a little bit different than
what we're used to
seeing you know and it's time to reveal
those differences so that under so that
people can understand
that we really are all the same and we
are we really all want the same thing
which is ultimately love well said and
from love
to education star mj rodriguez told us
the importance of educating viewers
about lgbtq plus history
there's a lot of stories that are being
touched upon obviously the epidemic of
aids and
i think a lot of that has gone missed
and uninformed and
kind of gone forgotten and i think that
young individuals need to know about
stuff like this
it's imperative that they get the
information that has been happening for
years now about the series ending
co-creator ryan murphy said to go from
the beginning of my career in the late
90s when it was nearly impossible to get
an lgbtq character on television
to pose which will go down in history
for having the
largest lgbtq cast of all time
is truly a full circle moment for me
listen the only way
to win a trophy is if you work really
hard
i got some tricks up my sleeve i can
teach you if you want
and although many including myself are
saddened by this news
season 3 will no doubt continue to
inspire
although we know you'll be sad to see
the show go this season will be filled
with all of the love
and laughter and tears that you have
come to expect
from the evangelista family and while
chatting with billy in 2020
we of course tried to get him to spill a
little tea about where he'd like to see
the third season go i would like to see
pratel be in the relationship i'd like
to see pray tell
um confront his religious family and
maybe have
you know that religion versus lgbtq
conversation
that's where i would like for it to go
um so we'll see
[Music]
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos